materials supplied by microsoft
corporation may be used for internal
review analysis or research only any
editing reproduction publication
reblogged showing internet or public
display is forbidden and may violate
copyright law
can people hear me yeah okay sorry my
voice hasn't gotten back yet and
hopefully be back by tomorrow or
something um you know I wasn't going to
say anything because of the wise but I
can't resist doing two things one is I
have to acknowledge the people who made
this possible first of all of course
it's all of you thanks for accepting our
invitation and coming and spending the
two days but of course all the speakers
the session organizers the ones people
who did the research shook is demos
pretty much everyone else and the three
execs Jeanette pioc and Harry was
usually hiding somewhere in the back
there and really the amount of time and
effort that deep sleep put into making
this event a success was incredible you
know that's I don't know if I add up the
per minute cost of all that will be a
very expensive event I have filling but
then I can't forget most importantly
they wonderful wonderful head really
came in to us at the right time but also
want to thank all the organizers the lot
of people were involved the entire
outreach team really work together on
this it was you know really great to see
has come together and I'm pretty proud
being a part of that team but there are
five people I want to call out
specifically and maybe they can either
stand up or come here a Judith bishop
and Katherine vacantly the co-chairs who
put together the program did it and I'm
Catherine GE maybe it's not here at the
bar Kathleen come come come to the front
piece let the light shine on
so if you found anything wrong with the
program it's definitely one of those two
everything that was right is me thank
you both Sarah estimate that Maria
Christensen who did a lot of the work in
the background two faces names and faces
that you probably don't know her steam
but without whom you wouldn't be here
enjoying what thanks Aaron Mariah but
lost but not least the amazing Harold
who went through all the changes over a
log I said give them a big hand thanks
all of you you did such a good job you
had to keep on doing it for the rest of
you life thank you very much now it's my
pleasure to introduce Peter I that's the
other reason I'm here you know you under
my wife's is done and I wouldn't miss a
chance to introduce Peter Peter in as
you know is the head of the new
experiences technology group of DNR
research but more importantly most of
you know him as a long-standing academic
researcher a person who founded a
technology of his in TARPA most of you
know him but many of you know perhaps
only some of you know he's a charismatic
speaker very charming person not a
couple of things with peril you should
be very half he is such an avid
sportsman and gamer there's nothing that
you can beat him on including gambling
so I wouldn't bet against him on
anything if he tells you something just
believe it and the other thing is that I
caught him it was said very recently I
early adopt so having someone you know
who's in a senior level manager who
adopts technology ten times faster than
you do that's a little bit of trouble
but without in mind let me invite Peter
shares
Wow so it's a it's really I think that's
the most unique introduction I've ever
had and certainly this the sultry 'used
and that so thank you very much and but
I would also like to take this
opportunity to thank and congratulate on
and on who is really leading the whole
team to put this together down down so
it's been just an incredible experience
and I just want to start by thanking all
of you for being here I know it's it's
an imposition it is hard and takes time
and effort from all of your busy
schedules to come and spend time with us
I hope it has been a good use of your
time and I hope you've enjoyed it as
much as as I have we definitely don't
take it for granted and I am personally
also thankful that so many of you are
sticking out all the way to the end I
don't know how many key notes from
former CMU people you need to to listen
to but but I'm glad you're all sticking
on for at least one more so so thank you
I'm very honored as I was sort of
experiencing the events of the last
couple of days you know it's just so
inspiring you know I know it sounds
trite to say it but but I really mean it
you know the the Jeanette's opening
keynote yesterday that amazing panel
that Eric Horvitz had organized with
testing just amazing sweep of discussion
about the future of artificial
intelligence i I just was really taken
aback by really going all the way and
thinking in terms of kind of long
large-scale evolutionary terms in
learning just just amazing and and then
going throughout the day in really
tackling hit on some hard issues about
our community and the problems we have
with diversity in our in our community
and just looking at the stock numbers
even more starkly than before I was just
impressed with our willingness and
ability to kind of
go after those things and then today
just looking at all the demos I felt
very proud to have a chance to be a part
of an organization that has chance to
show off a little bit and engage with so
many of you most of that work was of
course in collaboration with so many of
you and then I was just in the ARV our
holocene session standing room only I
mean just you know you just get the
sense that maybe there's the possibility
that something big is about to change in
how we interact with and immerse
ourselves with the virtual with
computing just really incredible and as
I reflect on all that and over the last
year or so interacting with so many of
you in hallway conversations or as you
visited us or I've visited your labs and
universities or conferences and
workshops or various government
committee meetings and so on yeah it's I
just reflect on that I just left really
almost awestruck at what a vibrant
community we're all a part of and you
know it's just it's something that is I
think just so precious for us together
as a community we just are advancing
human knowledge and doing it in ways
they actually add meaning and help
people's lives and together we're
engaged in research that on the one hand
has tremendous practical and even
commercial value just the overheated
venture capital market again here not
only here but in China other parts of
the world in Europe and at the same time
that research is sometimes just achingly
beautiful and just in itself just in
that beauty seems to just add meaning to
our lives into to the meaning of our
society and what we're all about as a
species it's just an amazing thing and
then together as a community you know
there's just always one thing I noticed
yesterday
wow there's a lot of laughing going on
we have a heck of a lot of fun and it's
just an amazing an amazing amazing thing
and so it's just so precious and I am
left thinking that we are really in a
golden era right now now you know as I
was working on the tire tracks now one
thing that leaves auditors you look back
at all the amazing stuff that happened
in the 1960s the emergence of VLSI
design and birth of micro processors all
of the early work and compilers and
programming languages and so many other
things the birth of the ARPANET and you
look at that and think wow what a golden
era for computing research but when you
look at it now at least for me I'm just
thinking we are in a new golden era now
and it's just really an amazing thing I
couldn't be happier and couldn't feel
luckier that all of us together that we
are a part of this kind of community and
so time will tell if that's really the
case but I think undoubtedly we should
all feel very good about what we're
doing and it just revel in the time that
we have and just go for the gusto I
think Harry Shum in his fireside chat
with edolas Oscar yesterday was just
trying to say say that you know now the
time to really to go for it and so
that's I think the first thing I wanted
to say now of course what I want to
actually talk about today isn't just to
congratulate ourselves and pat ourselves
on the back although you know I think
that's a good thing generally to do I
instead wanted to address the topic
which is sort of alluded to by the title
of this talk and this has to do with the
possibility that there's some
fundamental changes to our field to our
research and maybe even fundamental
changes going on in our society that
have to do with the very nature of
research and how our society by which I
mean our
government the public and universities
in all of our other great institutions
in their society how they view and
tolerate the expense of what we do as
researchers and I took the title here as
a rip off of an op-ed that appeared in
The Washington Post a couple of months
ago by the mit president which was
entitled a better way to deliver
innovation which I thought was a
remarkably bold title it's always just
you're setting yourself up for failure
if you're going to declare that you have
a better way to deliver innovation is
such an important topic but such a hard
one but the op-ed I felt really struck
me in a certain way because in essence
it was also giving us or putting into
words the sense that i'm guessing all of
us feel that there may be as he put it
some profound shift in how our society
our country and really i think this is
global develops adopts and capitalizes
on innovation and this update goes on to
say that as you look at the different
mechanisms that we have for doing this
for capitalizing and developing and
adopting innovation that there are
shortcomings we don't quite see the
answers if we look at their venture
capital system raphael writes it writes
venture capital is simply not structured
at least the current system of venture
capital to support complex slower going
concepts that could end up being hugely
significant and then he goes on to say
it might be unrealistic to expect big
corporations I of course read that as
Microsoft to patiently invest in
technologies designed to impatiently
disrupt them men that just hit me right
between the eyes because we have a lot
of investments in Microsoft Research
that if I'm really honest with myself
are designed explicitly to try to
disrupt Microsoft as well as the other
players but this is what we try to do
and there's
real questions being asked about this
and of course is this also extends to
the government and ripe Oh Pines that
our government cannot effectively supply
the large-scale long-term funding needed
for new companies and products all of
this of course pertains to innovation
but it really speaks to our community
our community of researchers because
hidden behind all these words is the
implicit assumption that the innovation
starts with research and that puts
pressure on us as a research community
and so Eric Lander a month before that
gave this amazing lecture at the Library
of Congress and I'm i have to thank
edolas oscar for pointing this to me and
in this lecture he writes it's very much
worth reading there are bills in
Congress to ensure the accountability of
taxpayer dollars invested in science how
could you possibly complain about that
what can possibly be wrong with wanting
to have a clear case for how investments
in basic research pay off and of course
he states a fundamental truth a truth
that I think all of us in this room all
of us together as a part of the research
community know is true but it's so hard
to explain the answer is absolutely
everything is wrong with that that if
you try to plan things out too much you
miss the serendipitous extraordinary
returns but we feel this pressure
because the world has come to believe
our world has come to believe out of our
unreasonable past successes that the
future of innovation that our hopes for
innovation all start with us start with
research and as a result you know when
rife is talking about how to get
innovation faster more reliably he's
actually talking about how do we get our
research work to matter more in
innovation
that's where the pressure comes and
ground zero for this I think is the tech
industry our information technology
world I of course everything else
matters too but nowhere today is it
mattering more the information
technology and every company in our tech
industry is feeling this and so I do
want to talk specifically about the
reaction to this within Microsoft
Microsoft Research but let me just zoom
out a little bit I was starting at the
national level let me just zoom in not
quite to Microsoft Research and zoom in
just to the tech industry and as I look
around at the let me just use the term
innovation departments at all of our
competitor companies they're all feeling
pressure so wonderful people I'm sure
many of your friends at Amazon's lab126
they're doing some fantastic work but it
is really hard as they try to go fast to
do successful innovation and as I read
what's going on there and of course we
hear it not only in in the tech blogs
but we hear it from people that we hire
because there's just a lot of people
flowing back and forth between MSR and
Amazon and Google and Facebook and so on
and so we just hear a lot of things but
as I read some of these quotes Wow you
know it really resonates I hear that
you've probably heard it from him as our
people you probably heard from google
people over the last year or the
struggles to really deliver actually
ship somehow ship something innovative
out of advanced R&D activities in places
like Google X and as those things those
struggles kind of mount up you hear more
negativity and this creates reactions
CEOs notice these things and then you
have companies like Facebook starting to
set up and experiment with open research
labs and Facebook say a research lab
being very
prime example if people were impressed
last year with Mark Zuckerberg going to
China and speaking Mandarin what was
actually much more impressive was Mark
Zuckerberg going to nips and speaking
the language of AI researchers I mean
that that was an incredible thing that
he did and so that investment there and
of course we see this even going
overseas to China with Baidu's lab one
way I've talked about this to our people
in Microsoft Research is that five years
ago all of your research colleagues were
at universities today it is just as
likely for your research colleagues to
be at Google or Facebook or at amazon or
ebay you name it and the reason this is
happening is that smart CEOs in our
industry are desperate for that next big
thing and just like the mit president
seems to believe they believe that next
big thing is going to come from people
like us and so can we do it I think it's
a big question and of course we have a
smart CEO to a new one and he believes
the same way and he's really driven some
pretty amazing and deep changes now this
is a picture that holds a lot of meaning
for us in microsoft research right now
because this is a photograph taken at
sachin Adela's first public outing in
the Silicon Valley after he became the
CEO and this was at the recode
conference and he had the prime first
slot at recode and so when he was
invited to do excuse me to do this he
sent out an email to a bunch of people I
was very privileged to be on that email
asking telling everyone that he wanted
to bring one tech demo with him to
recode and so asking for ideas so you
can imagine all the pointy elbows and
the company coming out
and just to be frank about it at least
in my limited experience of Microsoft
Research MSR would not normally engage
in that conversation we just observe and
be ready to help out once decisions were
made and so lots of different ideas were
offered up and saw two listened and then
after a little while if you're a lot of
emails such it basically said I don't
get it I don't get all of these ideas I
want something that allows us to be
ahead to lead and be great he used those
phrases those vet phrase and he said I
would think skype has that which he
wanted something that really had real
market power and then we should focus on
this for both speech recognition and
translation and pour all of our MSR and
product rd into it and so you can see
there even in his very first public
Silicon Valley outing he was looking
first to MSR to be able to say something
and bring something to the world that
had the cunning print and aura of
innovation and let's face a speech
recognition machine translation speech
synthesis these are all the things that
only we do right now it's something that
is just cutting edge research
contemporary research again looking at
our community together for answers and
so you can imagine after that decision
was made and there were lots of hard
questions asked and such as stood his
ground that no this is what we're going
to do we were suddenly under the gun as
a research lab it was a mad scramble you
see here ger deep singh Paul that's Walt
Mossberg in the that who's the other
person without hair but gurney st.
Paul's the corporate vice president who
owns the skype business giving the demo
the demos working really great so that's
a big sense of relief and then such a on
stage as soon as the demo completes
publicly
pronounces oh and by the end of the
calendar year we will deliver the public
beta which was would have been nice if
he had discussed that with us first so
and but I tell that story because you
can see there's some deviousness and
really hard nosed management Bisaccia
and he is totally aided and abetted by
Harry Shum in all of this to push and
push and push to see the maximum that
can be extracted a lot of research here
and so the way I think about it and get
in the way they talk about is that we
suddenly have been thrust into the
middle of the innovation strategy for
Microsoft and we've been given a mandate
to do more and I mean mandate by the
dictionary definition meaning we have
been given the permission to do much
more in this company but also the
expectation to do more and it is pretty
darn exciting I'll say more about that
as we go on now i do want to take a
little bit about it's got translating
i'll say something about the technology
and the research in it but the other
element of our new CEO is he has defined
a very aspirational the way i actually i
use the word corny mission statement
which is to empower every person and
organization on the planet very romantic
turn of phrase there to achieve more and
as I've come to understand the thinking
Skype translator was also just that kind
of empowerment idea is there an idea
about how to make money or generate
revenue that is the Skype translator now
in fact at the time that this decision
was made skype had two missions one is
to lower operating costs and increase
revenues and to to increase the
reliability of the skype service and now
along comes microsoft research with the
backing of the CEO with a technology
that cost three times more to deliver
per call and that is a research rickety
prototype
and so it is just the statement that
this this mission to empower people
really mean something that is really the
focus so to give you an idea of that I
think some of you have probably
experienced Skype translator and we've
been just so pleased to see how people
embrace the technology and people are
getting real work done for the fur in
ways they couldn't do before
granddaughters are talking to
grandmothers in a different country for
the first time it's just really
wonderful but on this empowerment issue
I'd like to show you just a short
two-minute video of this surprising
kinds of applications that come out of
technology like this so if you could
roll the video please I'll be great when
I'm 13 years old lost paper I got the
love you can imagine this makes it
difficult to communicate with people
when I met my future wife able to carry
only by spelling out letters on my hand
a month later we met again and I thought
you're taught herself yeah off the bat
this is just what strategy because there
is no fears
last fall to come to my office to tell
me about an idea that he had for
adapting Skype translator to a scenario
that would have to be useful to him Ted
being deaf can't make calls for skype
boa Skype translator because it produces
transcripts he could actually read the
response back from someone so we sat
down and talked about it for a little
bit and there were some pieces missing
in Skype translator so we need to
actually do something to make it more
appropriate for that scenario Salinger
for my meetings at work to be planned
headband to sometimes it's just always
possible it doesn't replace an ASL
interpreter a lot of other awful but one
can reach the last minute although these
features were really impactful for dead
in his work life really hit me was the
realization that there was a big impact
on its personal life I realized did you
see Skype translator like a call my wife
directly from the first time the relay
services did you can do this but they
are inconvenient and require time to
initiate the call with Skype translator
i just read the transcript I understand
which is sad it's really full of that 24
euros a kiss you learn sign language
entran boy well I can take him up or
step into hers so I was sitting back
thinking about it i'm looking at it and
realizing the impact that this could
have for me for people here at microsoft
of our customers for people with
deafness with hard of hearing all over
the world technology has that part it
can empower people to do things and make
things easier it's available now
download it give it a try and help us to
make this a better and better
I just really love that I love all of
these research stories where the
outcomes of research the intended
outcomes maybe they happen or not but
the unintended impacts end up being the
surprising serendipitous outcomes end up
being the really cool ones and I really
felt proud of this one say a little bit
more about Skype translator a little bit
later so you know getting back to the
beginning you know there's just this
just incredible hunger for innovation
just incredible thirst to more reliably
come up with the next big drivers of
value the next big drivers of impact on
people's lives the next big drivers of
expanding people's imaginations of
what's possible in this world and just
all that wrapped up innovation and that
pressure I believe comes squarely down
on researchers and on the research
community and so all of the turbulence
and the questions that that we here and
that we feel right now the sense that
maybe society is becoming less tolerant
of the expense of research all of those
things they're all coming from this
place at the same time it is also
something that is exhilarating for us
because it is us as a research community
that are being put front and center in
changing the world at least in my
limited career as a researcher I don't
think I've been in a situation where I
feel like our community is being asked
to do so much and being expected to do
so much and so I used this crazy story
and I'm going to tell it here and don't
the you know laughs at me too much but
it goes back to when I think I was six
or seven years old and I grew up in
small town in Upper Michigan
and my parents were under some summer
vacation I went to my first theme park
and I saw a roller coaster for the first
time oh god I wanted to I wanted to ride
that thing I knew I had to write it but
I my head didn't make it up to the red
line so I wasn't allowed so a year or
two past we go on another family
vacation and I see a roller coaster
again and this time I'm tall enough all
right so I get to ride the thing I get
strapped into that roller coaster car
and then as I'm going up that first hill
I realize oh god this is a big mistake
you've got to get me off of this thing
and then of course by the time I finish
that first ride it's just the best thing
in the world I need to write it again
that's a story I tell to people through
our researchers to our engineers to our
partners and other parts the company to
reporters to everyone and the reason I
tell it is i think that that is roughly
speaking the situation that us at the
Research Committee that we are in today
if I reflect on this I think that we
have always believed in ourselves as
research we've always believed in the
part of research we've always believed
we could do more for our company or for
our University or for community or for
the world if only we were given the
mandate to do more and now that we have
been giving that mandate it's kind of
scary there are uncomfortable questions
may we get a little nauseous hopefully
no one folds out okay but things happen
and that is the situation that I you
know where the dog that for years was
trying to catch the bumpers on the
passing cars and now we finally caught
one and now what and at least I can
speak I think pretty much for microsoft
research and i can see jeanette shaking
your head that is definitely the
situation in microsoft research day but
i suspect that this is a much broader
thing
so what what can we do about that what
should we be doing about that and you
know it has been a real thought process
and a turbulent one it's been a
rollercoaster ride but one of the things
that has always been the case for
microsoft research is that Microsoft
Research has done a lot of
experimentation we've always sort of
tinkered with models and reason we've
been able to do that is we've been
blessed with resources we have about
1,250 people worldwide we have a lot of
funding resources we can try a lot of
different things we can try different
approaches different philosophies to
management we can try different ways to
organize ourselves and and traditionally
emma Starr has done a lot of that some
of you have probably heard of
experiments like the impossible things
initiative that was something that Rick
rashes started or an extreme computing
group or many many others that didn't
actually even have names that things
that we just tried and so we are
embarking actually on a much more
significant kind of experiment now in
the creation of an organization in
microsoft research that we've been
calling a Microsoft Research next and
next it's sort of double entendre but
the actual acronym is new experiences
and technologies and so I've been
spending the last nine months
exclusively focused on building and
trying to figure out what emma's our
next should be and so I'd like to just
say a little bit about it I don't want
to get into organizational detail it's
kind of boring but try to give some
overall management philosophy around
what this is I call this a projects
organization and that's actually an
allusion to the DARPA notion of project
and by project that means several things
one is that we try to organize people in
ms our next into subgroups that are all
aligned or going towards some clear goal
and I'll give you some examples of these
things but if you think of the Skype
translator team
Skype translator team has the goal to
eliminate the language barrier for all
Internet connected people in the world
so that's a goal and it's something that
actually to some extent or another can
be can be easily assess and so that
implies that the structure of ms our
next is highly interdisciplinary because
to do something like the Scott
translator you need distributive systems
researchers because you're trying to
deliver a very complicated and expensive
service to 350 million active users you
need speech recognition you need machine
translation you need HCI many many
different kinds of people have to form
that group and that's a little bit of a
deviation from the way MSR has been
organized in the past where we have
really gone for serious intellectual
depth and organized ourselves into
groups around the grand disciplines of
computer science and related fields like
machine learning like computer vision
like cryptography and so on a second and
this is sort of an allusion to the hull
Meyer Catechism if you know about that
is we talk about exit strategies so pick
some time in the future one year from
now five years from now 15 years from
now but imagine that future point and
some change in the world that you want
to affect hopefully for the better and
now what is some credible plan for
getting there from here and of course
it's research so we know that everything
changes today you get smarter in the
plans change every day but we try to
have always in our project teams a
thought of what we want the world to be
like at what time and some notion of how
we think we can get there even if that
has to be revised on a near daily basis
and so we talk about this in terms of
the strategies because that also means
that we think about how we will actually
get things out into the real world or
out into whatever community of interest
we want to have an impact on we've tried
to change how we control resources and
funding and then start next to allow a
lot of buffer so that we can have an
agile response so there's a new idea
that comes up and we want to just invest
quickly we can do that there was just a
recent incredible idea for a DNA storage
device that came out of some
collaborations between the University of
Washington and Microsoft Research and so
what we want to be able to do when we
see extending things like that it's if
we can really understand and push on the
accessible bowls and the clear exit
strategies that we can very quickly like
within a few days provide the resources
and the people to really get started
this really comes from Harry Shum and
from satya nadella but we've tried to
instill an N ten mandate to give our
project teams the right to take things
all the way to the end and in some of
the Amazon X projects that involve
actual setting up businesses to actually
act like startups and find ways to
actually deliver all the way to paying
customers if necessary now most of our
research projects aren't like that but
all of them actually have now the
ability to own things and deliver them
all the way to the end and then finally
a big thing you have to do with culture
you know there's a phrase that we've
been using that we want to celebrate
innovation and reward great execution on
our research work but we want to worship
impact and that is just sort of a credo
to try to instill this idea that what
we're trying to do is actually bring
things bring what we can do
out into the world and so this is not
that far off from what MSR has always
been and with our has always done things
like this in the past but we are now
just trying to be a little bit more
focused at least for my part of emma's
are being a little bit more focused and
organized and intentional about it I
wanted to tell you a little bit about
the just give you several examples give
you an idea of the kinds of things that
have started it's only been nine months
it's still early but I think I can give
a few examples give you an idea and as I
do this one thing I want to say is that
the way we got started with MSR next is
basically Jeanette Harry and I kind of
sat down and we sort of try to find
people who might be genetically
predisposed to this next model and move
them under me people who might have less
comfort all the things people always
evolve would not have to be a part of
emma starr next and then of course we've
been hiring a lot and that hiring has
been quite a lot of work I think we've
hired well over 100 new people since
since last winter and so it's a work in
progress and so I think the point of
this image is to state that there's a
little bit of a sense of changing the
engines on the airplane while it's still
in flight and so so as as I describe
things there's some things are more
aspirational than real but i'll try to
to be as grand as possible and the
examples I'm choosing are also examples
of projects that had their origins
outside of MSR and the reason to do that
is just to try to emphasize the things
that maybe can be pushed and brought in
from other parts of the company into the
amateur model okay so I talked a little
bit about the Skype translator and of
course there was this sort of surprising
push from the very top and we've been
real
it's just been a huge amount of work but
wow really just so much fun the
challenges have been just incredible I
mean just the scaling challenges alone
have been really tremendous and we've
just barely scratch service we've been
very cautious we had a very cautious
preview program that was very limited
and the only client application that has
this functionality is the modern or
metro app for windows which has a very
small user base right now as we've been
very cautious about the scaling but that
will be changing over the next few weeks
and months but we are now on the road to
just developing and releasing more and
more languages and studying very
carefully for some of our preview
partners on what people do one of the
interesting things about Skype
translator and our experience is we've
been learning a lot about what I call
intimate conversation and what do I mean
by that well all of our speech and
machine translation models for the most
part we're trained on transcripts of
lectures and of speeches trained on the
on business transactions like you trying
to talk to a hotel clerk who speaks the
different language you talking to a
waiter or waitress you talking to a taxi
driver so I call those all either formal
conversations or conversations business
conversations between strangers but when
people are using skype they aren't
strangers it's that granddaughter
talking to a grandmother it's two
co-workers who work for the same company
and they're trying to get work done
there is a different vocabulary and a
different kind of sensed there's an
amazing amount just singing to each
other that goes on in skype people tell
jokes to each other all the time people
laugh all sorts of things happen so our
models just like Google's we're just
nail the talk to
hotel clerk scenario just great so
that's all fine but he'll now that we've
already scoped translated that seems
damn boring there is something much more
human much more intimate about the kinds
of things that we're learning and as a
result the models that were having to
ship are for the most part all coming
out brand-new and we are learning so
much about this kind of familiar
intimate conversation and what is so
exciting to me besides the fact that
we've had to do some groundbreaking work
in disfluency removal and segmentation
and so many other kinds of things we
think that are actually controversial if
I'm trying to talk to someone in China
and maybe I you know I'm trying to
become friends the joke i have is if i'm
trying to get the date in shanghai and i
have a few arms and oz is it right is
meaning lost if those arms and ozzard
are removed as they are right now with
our latest technology it's these are
very interesting questions and as we get
to the bottom of these things what opens
up for us and what is so exciting is
that we get new business opportunities
because if you look at a big part of our
business which is the enterprise
business and our support for things like
meetings this is a typical me in fact I
hope Lily Chang isn't too embarrassed
this is a photograph of a group research
meeting in Lily Chang steam look at that
meeting look at that scene can't you
hear in your heads what's going on there
that is not you know like one stranger
talking to a hotel clerk was another
stranger there is two different kind of
thing so to be able to process the
speech in these kinds of settings I
believe our experience with Skype
translator is giving us some insights
we're learning something about human
discourse and it's just incredibly
exciting and so I just see whole new
vistas and fundamental research opening
up before us
that Skype translator is in the category
of projects that I called strategic
collaborations with product engineering
so we are joined at the hip with the
skype engineering team and our success
is skype success we're just all in with
them the work that we do with hollow
lens is very similar the work we do with
Bing with office and so on is very
similar and in one way when we do that
kind of work were being very respectful
to the mindset and the thought process
in the product engineering groups but
it's important for research also to have
a part that either openly or not openly
disrespects the thinking in in the
project engineering groups that actively
tries to kind of not just take for
granted what goes on there and so we
have another part of our portfolio that
really tries to be disruptive that
really tries to work on high ambition
goals that if met if successful would
completely upend everything and so we
have quite a few projects in this bit
and we haven't been very public or open
with any of the projects to this point
although we as you watches over the next
few months you'll see more and more come
to light but one that we have talked
about publicly it's our quantum effort
and the quantum effort is again
something that has a very clear angle I
think you've heard about some of it if
you attended the quantum session
yesterday we have a program written by
crystal Sephora and routine for
computing energy minimum for ferredoxin
and we want to execute that program
because executing that program we
believe would lead to fertilizers and
other nitrogen fixation technologies
that would have a significant commercial
value as well as the potential to
eliminate world hunger so now what
need to do to execute that program
that's our goal and the only way we know
of is with a quantum machine and we've
gone far enough to understand that the
quantum machine would be able to execute
that program and so now we're on this
path and we've been doing some work that
i think is incredibly exciting it's a
long path but it is planned out and we
have dates in mind those days seem to
change all the time but you know because
our confidence in what we're doing and
how good we're feeling about things
changes all the time it is research
after all but we're thinking about those
things but the cool thing about this and
this is something we all know another
fundamental truth about research is that
when you go for these high bitchin
things and if you're very focused you
know for sure that there will be lots of
interesting useful spin-offs along the
way and so this top middle image is this
beautiful image which i think is going
to be so important that is an interface
between indium arsenide and aluminum and
you can see it's atomically perfect and
so we have managed to find engineering
process for doing that now why is that
important well indium arsenide is a
standard semiconductor aluminum at low
enough temperatures is a superconductor
and when you have this atomically
perfect interface and you go to low
temperatures the Cooper pairs that
define the superconducting
characteristics of the aluminum start to
inhabit that subject conductor and when
that happens you suddenly have
superconducting properties in a
semiconductor and now all sorts of
things microwave detectors and various
sorts of devices that we know how to
fabricate today in some in a
semiconductor substrate you just start
dreaming about all sorts of things and
so these sorts of possibilities of
spin-offs the things that we learn by
trying to engineer things at extremely
low temperatures just have far-reaching
consequences even if we never make it to
executing Chris
ferredoxin program Krista and Dave
workers harry and jeanette mentioned
catapult so in this team their goal the
way I look at their goal is that from
now until 20 25 they have to keep our
cloud on the trajectory of Moore's law
and so that's pretty hard now the thing
about this and is as you think about
doing this you have to think about this
series of architectural and technology
changes and in the short term the
technological approach that has been
taken is to look at a reconfigurable
computing fabrics in our data centers
and so working in great partnership with
Derek to and his team in bing we ran a
large pilot about 1,600 servers on the
Bing ranking load that was very very
successful give us a lot of confidence
we're now on the path actually to
carrying the full Bing ranking load in a
few months in FPGA boards and that then
has created the possibilities that we
can go actually whole hog potentially at
some point to our entire cloud and
already the cloud business Asher has
been publicly demonstrating the
possibilities of encryption at line
speeds for free in our cloud using this
kind of technology what's really
exciting though to us it is not anything
that I just said all of that was just a
way of incubating the technology to
persuade our company to pour in the
hundreds of millions of dollars required
to do that kind of deployment but when
we look at this what we dream about is
looking at the global network that was
built for our data centers and
overlaying on that global network a
whole new kind of gigantic distributed
computer
based entirely on reconfigurable logic
and now what do you think we might be
able to do with that and all sorts of
great dreams happen there and so this is
a third category of projects that we've
been trying to funds that I refer to as
incubations there are research ideas
that we've managed project at them we've
met to test them but now they're they're
ready to kind of go much bigger and that
that scale maybe give us new research
possibilities and as you look at those
things there's so many other things that
all have that kind of flavor they have
some clear goal some goal and some time
frame that gives us an idea of what kind
of change we want to make in the world a
plan for getting there a plan for
getting the things out in the world and
then giving us some freedom to play
around those things by putting enough
resources around and so this is an
experiment will it work out I am Not
sure but we're pretty darn excited so
far even as early going so I do want to
take some questions but before I do that
let me just close with the final thought
we are just incredibly excited and just
the the kind of impetus and the mandate
from Harry shaman from such and adela
just being a part of microsoft research
and the great collaborations
interactions with not only the labs and
Jeanette's whole organization but XD
Huang's intelligence services group in
yu ting closed group have just all been
fantastic but i don't want to lie either
this has been an incredibly turbulent
year it really has been a roller coaster
ride and is I think about all of the
things that we've gone through this past
I reflect on it and I just am incredibly
proud now to be a part of a company that
is willing to take the kinds of risks
that it's taking right now a company
that really seems to get it and believe
in what research can possibly do if only
given that mandate so this rollercoaster
metaphor is a metaphor allegory allegory
is actually very real I think for all of
us and as we think about how this future
will play out for us I'm hoping that as
a research community we can actually
prove that all of the assumptions that
people seem to have that innovation is
driven by research people don't often
times say it but it's actually implicit
in what everyone is saying it's implicit
in the kinds of doubts and the questions
that people are asking about the cost of
research it's implicit when people are
asking about the ROI and wanting to
understand it we now are in the position
with this mandate to prove that that is
all true and correct and so I don't see
any way as Harry put it yesterday that
we can do without all of us working
together I'm pretty excited pretty
confident and really looking forward to
seeing how this plays out so thank you
very much for listening I wanted to
leave a little bit of time so I think we
have five or ten minutes for questions
so I'm happy to take any questions that
there are any yes
yeah so the question was I started early
on with the quotes that were really
looking academic research but and then
moved industrial research and now can I
bring it back to the academic research
you know I think that the fundamental
questions that are being asked in
academia and Industry for industrial
research academic research are my view
now and I think I have some perspective
because i have now I've been in both
places I think they're fundamentally the
same I think the urgency in computing
research in industry is extremely high
right now because right now the tech
industry writ large doesn't know what
the next big driver of commercial value
will be you know if the apple watch
takes off and if suddenly every person
in the first world starts spending six
hundred dollars for a wearable computer
we'll all be happy for a few more years
but barring that it's not clear what the
next big drivers are going to be so
there's a desperation and urgency and so
that's why you see our CEO and the other
CEO is really starting to like look with
some desperation at their industrial
research or innovation departments for
answers but if you take that urgency
away I don't see any difference it feels
the same to me when I was at DARPA I
visited about 30 universities and labs
during my time at DARPA 31 I think and
you know you could just feel all the
great stuff going on but also the kind
of worries and anxieties people have
about funding and those worries were
deeper than where is the next grant
going to come from the worries were kind
of there's an undercurrent of just
concerned about wow it's society going
to continue
to understand in a basic research and
its value and to tolerate the the
expense of it so the urgency might be a
little bit different but I think we're
all in this together and so when I look
maybe I'm putting too much on MSR but I
do view us as important in our community
because we are in some ways at the
vanguard of that pressure right now
because not only are we a part of this
open research community but we are just
happen to be in a company in a very
turbulent industry in a very turbulent
time I'm probably so by the way yeah
like I'm probably being overly dramatic
about things so you can take what i do
and tone it down by by a few notches but
i think i'm saying something relatively
true yes
question for you or possibly for any of
the other executives who are there you
talked a lot in sort of generalities
about how we should manage research and
innovation and whatnot what does ms are
not have what are you planning on doing
going forward where were you planning on
growing and are there limits to what you
think MSR can accomplish oh yeah so
there certainly are limits I let's see
so there it gets to census a question
one is kind of research directions where
so what does our portfolio balance look
like in terms of technical or research
directions another one way to look at it
is what sorts of modalities or
management philosophies might we try to
adopt and so they're interesting answers
to both to both questions you know when
we look at areas where Jeanette and
Harry and I kind of think about Wow are
we missing the boat on some things
topics that come up often are things
like a general science a lot as we've
gotten to see the importance of tangible
devices and so on there are more more
questions about materials various
aspects of materials and material
science yesterday robotics came up that
kind of physical actuation in the
mechatronics there there are very
interesting questions about this whole
cyber physical systems or IOT space so
there are many many directions and we
thread about these things all the time
in terms of other innovation strategies
we're trying to be as creative and open
minded about things as possible one
thing that happens that most of
universities that's hard for us but
we're looking at ways to do it is most
professors if they have great ideas or
graduate students they can go spin and
take a leave of absence for a year or
two spin off and try something and with
the comfort that they can come back and
so
that is something that is much much more
difficult Microsoft Research and so
we're thinking about things like that
because it's important not only to
maximize the potential for impact of the
research that we do but also to sort of
inject that kind of entrepreneurial
thinking in the culture of MSR and so
there are different thoughts like that
and so as we're sort of just having our
hallway discussions having our formal
meetings reviews and so on right now
we've just ended one fiscal year and
start a new one and it's a kind of a
prime time that we that we think about
these things so ultimately as big as we
are we do have limits and so we're
always feeling like we're hitting those
limits and so we have to make choices
and and so we we do what every
department head what every professor
with a research group what every Dean
has to do which is is to try to make
those choices
so seeing if unless there are any other
questions so let me then close I will be
out I think all of us will be out in the
little reception afterwards thank you so
much again for coming we really really
are grateful for all of your time and
attention and I hope you enjoyed it each
year microsoft research helps hundreds
of influential speakers from around the
world including leading scientists
renowned experts in technology book
authors and leading academics and makes
videos of these lectures freely
available